[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france 24
notre invité et leonid volkov c'est le
conseiller principal de d'alexis une
avanie le critique du kremlin qui est
emprisonné il est avec nous depuis
vilnius merci d'être avec nous avec
plaisir je veux avant votre réaction au
mot utilisé par le président américain
joe biden dans sa visite en pologne il a
décrit vladimir poutine comme un boucher
et après dans un discours il a dit que
cet homme ne peut pas rester au pouvoir
la maison blanche a ensuite nuancé ses
déclarations mais est-ce que vous
l'interprétez de cette façon est ce que
vous ne pensez pas que c'est un
changement dans la perception de
vladimir poutine à la maison blanche à
washington
un changement attendu depuis longtemps
je soutiens complètement ce qui est dit
le président battle monsieur poutine est
un boucher a trop vite un criminel de
guerre et il ne peut de fait pas rester
au pouvoir
l'ennui c'est que c'est ce que nous
explique on discutait année
l'empoisonnement de skripal de navel ni
les centaines de prisonniers politiques
l'annexion de la crimée la slack contre
le boeing m h 17 avaient été des indices
suffisants angela merkel a dû
publiquement en 2014 qu'elle pensait que
vladimir poutine avait je cite perdu
tout contact avec la réalité
le monde savait qu'il avait perdu le
contact avec les réalités mais le monde
attendu pendant huit ans ce qui a d'une
certaine manière autorisé la tragédie
que nous voyons
en ukraine les choses semblent bouger la
russie semble modifier sa position elle
affirmé à réduire radicalement sa
présence militaire au tour de kiev de la
ville de tergnier yves évidemment tout
cela reste mouvant mais est-ce que vous
avez l'impression
que peut-être la dîmière poutine est en
train de se rendre compte de la réalité
qui est qu'il ne peut pas gagner cette
guerre
et qu'il a fait une erreur en silence en
bien l'admirent poutine voulait faire
une blitzkrieg il voulait être à kiev en
72 96 heures après l'attaqué initiale
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
parachutistes sont saisis de l'aéroport
de costauds mail c'est la raison pour
laquelle les blindés ont filé à toute
allure vers kiev et dès les premiers
jours de la guerre mais il a échoué et
cela fait plusieurs semaines qu'il est
clair que ça biskri des jouets
il ne la mets que maintenant
mais c'est trop tard car beaucoup trop
de dégâts ont été causés
car beaucoup de sang et s'est répandu
pour rien
comment vladimir poutine va t-il
expliqué pourquoi il l'a détruite en
deux villes ukrainiennes pourquoi il a
tué dont deux civils et tant de soldats
russes je n'arrive pas à l'imaginer sa
machine approche de propagande est très
forte et très compétente mais même pour
sa propagande cela sera un véritable
défi que d'expliquer
qu'une fois encore tout se déroule selon
le plan
le plan initial n'était pas d'envahir
kiev mais de s'emparer des région de
lougansk de donetsk et ainsi de suite la
propagande va bien sûr tenté de le faire
elle tentera d'être convaincante mais
j'espère qu'elle et chora de nouveau
est-ce que vous pensez que la population
russe
aussi l'interpréter comme vous malgré la
propagande et on a vu la façon dont des
réseaux sociaux sont fermés comme des
médias sont fermées en russie mais
est-ce que vous pensez que les russes
vont se rendre compte il y a un problème
est que le régime n'est pas aussi
puissant qu'il le pense
oui bien sûr la russie est un immense
pays 140 millions d'habitants très
divers très divers aussi dans leur usage
médiatique
on ne peut pas juger le peuple russe
comme un ensemble d'aucuns croient rond
jusqu'au bout à la propagande comme
certains allemands l'ont fait jusqu'en
mai 1945 mais d'aucuns de l'autre côté
commence à comprendre ce qui se passe et
c'est très important c'est l'un des
fronts de cette guerre il y a trois
fronts bien sûr le front militaire qui
est le plus important on voit les forces
armées ukrainiennes défendre leur
territoire mais il ya aussi un front
économique sur lesquelles se déploie les
sanctions et où des pressions sont
exercées sur poutine pour qu'il mette
fin à la guerre et il ya le front de la
formation sur lequel nous nous battons
nous tentons de percer le rideau de la
propagande pour faire comprendre aux
russes ce qu'est la situation réelle à
autant de risques possibles en russie
s'il n'y a pas de soutien pour la guerre
en interne
les soldats refuseront de se battre
c'est beaucoup plus difficile pour
poutine de rester au pouvoir
si sa guerre n'est plus soutenue en
interne et je dirais que petit à petit
nous faisons certains progrès même si ça
je n'ai pas encore une percée sur ce
front side car il y à un changement de
l'opinion en russie un changement
visible au cours des dernières semaines
à venir alexis navales menées la semaine
dernière à une cour l'a reconnu coupable
de fraude la condamnée à neuf ans de
prison il avait déjà été condamné à deux
ans et demi de prison il est censé être
dorénavant emprisonné dans une prison
dites à haute sécurité
ce qui veut dire des conditions beaucoup
plus dures de détention selon certains
reportages
il est déjà harcelé en prison est donc
une question très grave est ce que vous
avez peur pour sa vie s'il va dans une
telle prise en cours oui bien sûr
il est détenu par les personnes qui ont
tenté de le tuer il ya un an et demi au
cours de l'année écoulée nous avons
tenté de le protéger par la
médiatisation en faisant parler d'
alexeï navalni et de ce qu'il fait
cette guerre attire bien sûr l'ensemble
de l'attention médiatique
ce qui fait passer une nouvelle nuit au
second plan donc nous pensons qu'il est
plus en danger que jamais et c'est
pourquoi il est si important que nous
parlions de lui et que nous ne
l'oublions pas
cette peine de neuf ans est une pure
formalité administrative tout le monde
savait dès le début qu'il serait de fait
condamné à perpétuité la question est de
savoir qu'il survivra à qui tiennent à
navalni une avanie à poutine navalni est
le prisonnier politique personnelle de
poutine et s'il meurt il sera relâché
automatiquement en d'extinction cette
guerre
considérablement réduit le temps qu'il
passera au pouvoir est ainsi
considérablement réduit la durée de
détention de l'ancien président est ce
que vous pensez encore entre temps il
est vraiment en danger
bien sûr et le monde qui devrait garder
un oeil sur lui très bien vous avez
garder un oeil sur les richesses
supposées de vladimir poutine vous avait
révélé il ya peu il ya quelques jours
des liens entre lui et un yacht
le shéhérazade en affirmant que
l'équipage était largement composée de
membres des forces de sécurité russes
est ce que c'est important pour vous de
continuer à faire ses révélations qui
sont évidemment nié par le kremlin
c'est très important
car cela nous aide
à combattre sur le front économique cela
nous aide à identifier les faiblesses de
poutine cela nous aide à trouver les
leviers qui sont utiles contre lui notre
enquête la plus connue sur son palais
sur le palais de poutine sur la côte de
la mer noire
montre la petitesse de ce personnage il
a eu 20 ans de pouvoir personnel
illimité à la tête du pays le plus grand
du monde de l'un des plus riches il
aurait pu construire le meilleur système
universitaire le meilleur réseau de
routes asphaltées
il a choisi au lieu de cela de
construire un palais pompeux plein de
torture et de tapis rouge cela dit
quelque chose de sa personnalité cela ne
nous aide à comprendre sa personnalité
je pense ici son yacht de taille
impérial aux biens luxueux qu'il possède
tout cela nous aide à savoir comment
traiter avec lui en tant qu'occidentaux
il faut s'attaquer à son argent car
l'argent est très important pour lui
oui est-ce que vous pensez que
l'occident savait tous que vous révéler
depuis un moment et avait décidé de ne
pas le mettre sur la table jusqu'à
maintenant
oui bien sûr
jusqu'à aujourd'hui l'occident a profité
des milliards de dollars
générés en russie voler est ensuite
investi en occident ce qui enrichit les
économies occidentales
des milliards investis dans des villas
sur la côte d'azur dans des yachts en
allemagne où des propriétés à mayfair à
l'ong cet argent a contribué à
l'enrichissement des économies
occidentales et l'occident fermer les
yeux quant à l'origine de cet argent
est-ce que vous pensez que cette période
est révolue et que la pierre en ukraine
et le déclic que vous espérez
histoire oui mais le prix à payer est
trop élevé
cela fait plusieurs années que nous
appelons à des sanctions personnelles
visant les biens de poutine et de ses
amis oligarques bien c'est une bonne
chose que cela est enfin lieu mais quel
dommage que cela se fasse un prix si
élevé une dernière question une enquête
de bellingham insider et la bbc a
découvert que dans les jours et les mois
précédant son assassinat en 2015 le
leader d'opposition boris nemtsov été
suivi par des membres de la même équipe
qui a ensuite suivi à l'excès un aval ni
et l'a empoisonné apparemment et qu'il
faisait partie du fsb des forces de
sécurité russes est ce que vous
considérez que cela dit beaucoup sur
vladimir poutine et la façon dont ils
s'occupent des opposants qui se met sur
sa route
tout d'abord permettez moi de vous
corriger car il ne s'agit pas d'un
empoisonnement supposée il s'agit d'un
empoisonnement ce qui a été prouvé de
manière irréfutable le fait qu'alex et
navalni a été empoisonné sur ordre de
poutine est aussi évident que deux et
deux font quatre
le fait que la même équipe et assassiné
boris nemtsov à nos opposants
extrêmement connue vice-président du
gouvernement russe qui est très
important car cela montre que la machine
à tuer de poutine son système de
meurtres arbitraires des opposants
politiques
existent depuis depuis longtemps depuis
le temps où les dirigeants du monde lui
serrer la main ou poutine se mettait en
scène comme un homme de bonne foi et
respectable au g20 à ce moment là déjà
il assassiné ses opposants politiques il
n'est pas devenu fou depuis deux ans il
l'a toujours été
leonid volkov
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
et merci d'avoir regardé cet entretien
sur nos antennes
[Musique]